the nandhu also known as the rear first
came to northern Germany from South
America in 2000 now it's made of self at
home in the state of
mecklenburg-vorpommern
it's an invader and a conqueror
area expert Frank Phillip counts the
birds twice a year this time he can't
seem to find any at all maybe the long
cold winter decimated them
but then he finds a feather where's the
rest of the bird
not far away as it happens it's feeding
quite happily then and was in our teeth
the Rhea is a species that thrives
extremely well in our cultivated country
sides we have lots of canola and grains
planted all over and lots of pasture
land that's advantageous to this species
canola in particular helps the Rhea
survive the winter for the bird it's an
ideal food source much to the dismay of
canola grow hands-free to Gruber the
birds are eating up more and more of his
crops every year and he's powerless to
stop them
everywhere he looks the leaves are
bitten down to the stalk perhaps a third
of my crops is canola and if I lose it I
lose a third of my revenue think about
what that means it's enough to finish me
off does this other for me I go broke I
go bankrupt simple as that
I couldn't absorb it I just couldn't
manage with revenue down at third I Nam
get Connie
Germany's Environment Ministry is aware
of Hans frigate Gruber's plight they say
it's a sad but isolated case and nothing
can be done because the rear is
protected by the Washington Convention
on endangered species the highest that
means we're not allowed to hunt
interfere with chase or kill the RIA nor
can we interfere with its habitat
lifting so the rear is free to enjoy
Miglin Berg for Pullman's full
hospitality but do the giant flightless
birds pose any kind of threat at
Berlin's Technical University Ingo Cove
art has been looking into the impact
non-native species can have when an
invasive species is introduced humans
usually have something to do with it the
American crayfish is one example they
were introduced after the European
crayfish had declined because of water
pollution and now the American crayfish
is turning out to be a problem because
it's brought in a fungus infection
that's causing a massive decrease in the
native crayfish
that's a direct result of this fungus
infection and the consequences could be
devastating that begs the question did
the rear bring in any diseases for now
the birds under observation
conservationist Martin Bower says the
only real hazard the rear presents is
when they try to cross roads and
highways other invasive species post
much greater threats
this is a hundred metaphor google these
things are the consequence of the global
trade relations of vegetables and
flowers coming from Spain and the round
back slug coming along with them the
same goes for pests like moths they come
in with certain kinds of fruit and take
hold here partly in the greenhouses and
nurseries they can cause massive damage
to crops and go to an unwitting sofa
Hans Friedrich Gruber has found little
support for his problems with the rears
it's just gone but that's the way things
are he has little hope that nature will
eventually take care of the problem for
now they're completely safe because they
have no natural enemies the only one
they might have is the eagle which picks
up a chick now and then but that's not
much real expert Frank Phillip can't
give the farmer any encouragement either
this year's long winter has had no
effect on the bird breeding season has
begun and they're busy laying eggs
the problem isn't forehead compared to
spring last year the population is
greatly increased we have hard evidence
of that and the trend is set to continue
exponentially in the long term and how
many birds will there be in say ten
years in ten years we could easily reach
500 or maybe even a thousand birds if
the weather conditions are right
you